les 27 qui estime qu'en douze jours un
million six cent mille ukrainiens se
sont réfugiés en europe il pourrait être
à terme 5 millions bonjour leslie
carretero vous revenez tout juste de
roumanie vous étiez assis raide c'est à
la frontière avec l'ukraine d'abord
quelle est la situation sur place elle
est assez catastrophique de jour comme
de nuit ce sont des milliers d'exilés
qui passe le point de contrôle à syrte
qui se trouve donc comme vous venez de
dire à l'est de la roumanie ils ont
attendu des heures dans le froid quand
nous étions in et j'ai continuellement
et pour vous donner une idée quand nous
étions là-bas jusqu'à dimanche la file
d'attende pour pénétrer à cired
s'étendait sur 18 km et en une seule
journée on a pu assister à l'arrivée de
8000 personnes alors au total depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine le
24 février ce sont soixante dix mille
personnes qui ont débarqué à sir est
donc à peu près la moitié des 140 milles
arrivée comptabilisés dans toute la
roumanie alors la majorité des exilés
qui débarque sont des femmes et des
enfants vous le savez le président
zélande ce qui a décrété la mobilisation
générale pour contrer l'invasion russe
et donc les hommes ne peuvent pas passer
la frontière alors à la frontière on
voit beaucoup de femmes qui traînent des
valises beaucoup de bébés dans des
poussettes des enfants qui agrippe des
peluches les familles ont souvent fui le
pays avec leurs animaux de compagnie
alors c'est assez surprenant est rare de
voir ça à des frontières de voir des
animaux dans des petites valises ou dans
les bras des personnes et à leur arrivée
il ya un mouvement de solidarité qui est
en train de se former oui un énorme
mouvement de solidarité le long de la
nationale qui mène au poste frontière il
ya des dizaines et des dizaines de
tentes sous ces tentes on trouve de tout
des couches des produits d'hygiène de la
nourriture des jouets pour enfants et
tout est gratuit alors quand les
déplacés arrivent ils sont tout de suite
pris en charge par par des humanitaires
par des pompiers qui sont présents en
nombre dans la zone et aussi par de
simples citoyens volontaires alors ils
font la traduction entre le roumain et
l'ukrainien et distribuer de la
nourriture
il donne des jouets aux enfants ils
tirent les valises il emmène les exilés
vers leurs points vers leur lieu de
destination
alors en attendant de poursuivre leur
voyage les ukrainiens sont hébergés chez
des particuliers ou dans des centres
d'hébergement d'urgence rien qu'à siret
un stade et une école ont été
transformés en lieux d'accueil est liée
à environ 500 places alors samedi soir
on a suivi un prêtre qui depuis dix
jours passe ses soirées
la frontière ils transportent des gens
vers des centres d'accueil et les berges
aussi des personnes chez lui qui
m'expliquait que c'était très très dur
pour lui de vivre cette situation et de
voir les familles et surtout les enfants
dans cet état ya beaucoup d'enfants qui
pleure il me disait lui aussi qu'il a
qu'il n'avait pas pleurer depuis très
longtemps mais qu'en ce moment il
pleurait quasiment tous les jours voilà
témoignages terribles vous le disiez
leslie ces réfugiés sont accueillis chez
des habitants dans des infrastructures
dans des hôtels aussi qu'ils ouvrent
leurs portes gratuitement oui alors tous
les établissements de la région mais
déchante gratuitement à la disposition
des exilés même les hôtels de luxe
participent à l'effort un célèbre
d'hommes homme d'affaires roumain stefan
mandat qui part non qu'on a rencontrés à
et qui possède un hôtel 4 étoiles à peu
près 40 kilomètres de la frontière a
transformé la salle des fêtes de son
hôtel en dortoir et depuis le 24 février
ce sont à peu près 1500 personnes qui
sont qui sont passés dans son hôtel
alors le gérant installer des centaines
et des centaines de matelas par terre
quand nous y étions jeudi dernier il y
avait à peu près 300 personnes mais le
chiffre est assez fluctuant il peut y
avoir jusqu'à 600 personnes en même
temps dans l'hôtel où nous étions logés
aussi environ une demi-heure de siret
les propriétaires ont donné gratuitement
des chambres exil etc rien qui ne
pouvaient pas payer payer leur leur nuit
alors en effet c'est toute la roumanie
qui se montrent solidaires et les
roumains se prépare à ce que ça dure
samedi soir quand nous étions retourner
à la frontière on a vu des bénévoles
solidifier les tentes et les structures
existantes avec des palettes et des
morceaux de bois des planches de bois
donc signe que les roumains améliore les
structures déjà existantes pour
solidifier les installations qui étaient
qui ont été construites à la hâte